le système de la gestion de l'offre a
été créé à la fin des années 60 pour
réglementer la production laitière au
pays en fonction de la demande nationale
et ainsi éviter les surplus notre lait
étaient protégés moi ce que j'ai
aujourd'hui les producteurs laitiers
sont inquiètes
ils sentent que le système de la gestion
de l'offre est menacée nos producteurs
laitiers sont même allés manifester
devant les bureaux du ministre maxime
bernier cet été il leur a promis que les
quotas ne seraient pas touchés la
position dans le mental qui est préservé
douze pays participent aux négociations
pour ce nouvel accord économique trans
pacifique dont la nouvelle-zélande
l'australie le japon et les etats-unis
tout est sur la table
ce système de la gestion de l'offre
venait à disparaître
le président du syndicat des producteurs
laitiers ne donne pas cher des fermes
laitières au québec drogue beaucoup de
faire surtout dans les régions et léonie
d'euros disparus yvan bastien à 45
vaches
chaque vache veau 25000 dollars
c'est la valeur de ces quotas et ses
quotas c'est la moitié de ses actifs le
prix du lait qu'on reçoit 50 % sont bons
pour nos dépenses 25% salon pour faire
les paiements sur les emprunts condom
donc il nous reste 25 pour ça pour payer
nos envoyés pour vous il y a dix ans il
entrepris des travaux pour moderniser sa
ferme vous est ce que vous êtes endettés
oui de combien
j'ai un million de 1 millions de dettes
je fais des paiements de 500 par année
et grâce au système de quotas vous avez
quand même une certaine protection c'est
ça que vous êtes en train de me dire la
valeur de mes actifs si je prends mes
frères et le 14 à dépenser des millions
c'est quand on vaut plus rien mais
d'après mes terres convenable mais
d'après respirer de plus en plus de pays
abandonnent le système de la gestion de
l'offre pour un libre marché
ce fut le cas de l'australie en 2002
l'économiste daniel mercier coin est
allé constater sur place les effets de
la déréglementation 40 % des fermes
laitières ont disparu en dix ans les
prix ont diminué à la consommation de
l'ordre de 5% alors que les prix pour
les producteurs ça pourrait baisser de
30 40 % et par la suite la hausse des
prix a tout simplement repris
mécaniquement ou même groupe que
l'ensemble des aides humain mais le
système de la gestion de l'offre à ses
détracteurs
pour cet économiste le système de quotas
a fait son temps nous on est un pays qui
vivons en bonne partie du commerce
international par l'exportation est à
peu près deux emplois sur cinq qui en
dépendent au canada peu près la même
proportion québec
alors on ne peut pas rester à l'écart de
ces négociations bloquent les dernières
négociations avec l'europe ont ouvert
une brèche dans le système puisque le
canada a accepté l'implantation de dix
sept mille tonnes de fromages européens
les producteurs laitiers ici trois qu'à
force de bruges et le système de la
gestion de l'offre au pays
ce ne sera plus qu'une coquille vide
dans quelques années ici catherine
kovacs radio canada montréal